qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun à paris alors les transports en
commun parisiens je trouve ça assez
pratique mais pas toujours très
agréables au corps et votre frère et
dans penses quoi
ouais c'est vrai que c'est pratiquement
fait parfois il ya un petit peu les des
lacunes surtout au niveau de la
l'administration tout seul chez un petit
peu l'autre jour il ait pas de métro
belges étaient à pied ou jusqu'à dix
huitième adacore et votre soeur elle en
pense quoi
mais beaucoup parler et où c'est les
pieds à pied souvent oui mais voilà on
fait des choses comme ça il n'y a pas de
choix qu'est ce que vous pensez
transports en commun parisiens
eh bien ils sont très efficaces
c'est très facile de s'y repérer et
votre frère il en pense quoi superbe on
coule ça faisait longtemps que j'avais
pas vu en fonction des lignes on peut
attendre un peu plus ou moins attendre
donc c'est un peu chiant et votre frère
il en pense quoi
mais sans suivre en même temps un
certain doigté lui jaillit vida y est
bref je sais pas quoi rajouter le plus
sain c'est une excellente chose et
transports en commun mais on leur rend
pas la vie facile
d'accord et votre sale en pense quoi à
écouter six mois la poule mais ça ouais
et lawrence page et pâtures à paris
elles sont en banlieue déjà passé la
télé